Hàng trong game thủ vay kiến quay lục tung tăng quốc, viếp lấy tại Game Boss 2 không hay làm.
Bình năm Game Boss là sự kiến game lời nhất hàng năm được tổ chức tại thành phố chiming
cứ tụi nhiều ông lớn trong ngành game.
Năm này, nhà pháp hành viếp lấy, chức thuộc VTVC lần đầu tiên đầu bộ
mang theo sêu phẩm lục tung tăng quốc của hàng loạt phần quà siêu chất sản cho game thủ.
Tại ra hàng viếp lấy, game thủ đã được tránh game game play kịch tính.
Tham gia mini game suo đoệu và z nhiêu cùng cộng đồng phán của nhit.
Điểm nhấn không thể bỏ qua là loạt phần quà siêu xị, các bibera năm tinh cá,
áo thuân phín bản giới hạn loạt chút thiết kế đặc quyền.
Bình giữ nhịt sang chọc, mất quà tinh sảo mang đậm giộn lục tung tăng quốc.
Những món quà này đã khiến hàng trong game thủ đứng uổi không in,
sẽ thằng dài để chức ím và zinh về chiến lợi phẩm.
Thủ hút hàng trăm nạn rửa chơi này sau khi ra mắt,
lục tung tăng quốc tức tục giữ nhịt quay các bạn áp đếp đình cao.
Còn các sự kiện đuột tóc linh xưa vơ tảng quà hủ như iPhone 12 Pro mắc hay à bộ vật.
Sự kiện Việt Nam Game Boss 2 không hai làm một lần nữa khẳng định xức hút mạnh địa của tựa
gây này khi ra hàng viếp lấy luôn chất kiến người tham gia.
Bởi lối chơi chính thuật sâu sắc, tính năng đa giảng và những phần tưởng hợp sẫn.
Lục tung tăng quốc không chỉ là điểm sáng tại Game Boss 2 không hai làm mặt còn là tựa gây mạng chơi để mọi ghê thu hình phục sáng xơn,
hàng định bản định đế vường.